thank you hark your gifting five
appreciate that
if you were gifted to the sub you can
say thank you
if you're brand new to Twitch and you
don't know what a subscriber is
it's uh basically a way of supporting
the channel
get some perks
get ad reviewing and emotes hey we have
a staffer gamut
so
about a week ago I posted a YouTube
video that was titled
I killed the staffer gamut
and then the next video I posted
was a video
called the Stafford gamut is alive
so now it's time to kill the Stafford
gamut again
I don't play D3
and I'll try and be instructive here
we'll try and refute the Stafford as
best as possible
so D3 is the recommended move it does
Block in the bishop
there's other openings where sometimes
this can be inaccurate because you want
your Bishop outside the pawn chain
but because we've already won a pawn
it's really just about consolidating and
preventing
the opponent from the beginning
yeah Stafford Gambit's refutation time
so opponent's taking their time
I mean the really the only move black
should play here is Bishop C5
I'd be surprised if you'd see anything
else
and
yeah now this is actually where a lot of
people go wrong from the white side
because some people play this allowing
Knight G4
um H3 I've seen played which allows some
crazy Bishop F2 and Knight takes E4
so the best move is simply Bishop E2
uh preventing my G4 developing the
bishop
now when I play this move it looks like
maybe I want a castle but
uh that's another common mistake is
usually white should not Castle
so early especially when black plays H5
because the opponent wants to do this
and if I Castle then there's so many
lines where black can win quickly
um so here there's basically two
I would say two good moves but one is
much more recommended than the other uh
the two moves are H3 and C3
I'm gonna go ahead and play C3
which
is a move I recommend
um if H3 there's Queen D4 and it can get
actually kind of tricky
and then white has to walk a very thin
tight rope to to be better like castling
Queen D6 and
um I've enjoyed those lines for black
but the point of C3 is simply to expand
the D4
and I want to hit the bishop control the
center
maybe eventually D4 E5
now I'm trying to remember what my
opponent played in that uh
that first video I posted of killing the
Stafford I think I think they played
Bishop to B6
which is one of the better moves
the idea is
D4 is prevented because then Knight
takes E4 is playable
but usually when I'm black in this
position I like to play Knight G4
allowing D4 and then Queen H4
so we'll see what my opponent uh wants
to do
oh my Point's in the chat okay my
opponents said that they're turning off
the Stream
yeah sometimes when I'm I'm explaining
all these things I I wonder if the pawn
is actually listening but that's nice to
know that the opponent's uh
presumably will not be stream sniping
and that's usually recommended like if
you do happen to play me when I'm
streaming
I recommend yeah play on your own don't
listen in but then you can always watch
afterwards
yeah I will say if you're
if you're playing the Stafford or you're
you're like you study the opening
seriously which I guess I don't
recommend for too many players unless
you're really passionate about it
so I definitely fall into that category
then this is a position you should know
what to do if you're a regular Stafford
player
um
but my opponent's in a weird situation
where
they know that I know what the best line
should be
but we're going into it anyway
thank you T2 Davis
okay so I hit the bishop
I remember a time where like
this was
basically the end of the Stafford Theory
and then Jonathan trans came up with
this like crazy Queen H4 idea and then
it opened up a whole new world of
possibilities
so Queen F6 is not a move
I I've encountered
I'm actually trying to figure out the
difference here
because usually
yeah so usually I have this position
with a pawn already on G3
and use them black too
um but yeah usually black plays Queen H4
G3 and then Queen F6
so I'm wondering if I play F3 how is it
different
because usually if the Pawn's on G3 and
white plays F3 then there's H4 but after
F3
H4 doesn't really do anything
[Music]
let's go for it
I think I'll be winning a piece here
now there is a really funny line which
I'm wondering if we might go into
I'm going to trust that my opponent's
not listening or watching
uh the funny line is Queen H4
G3 Queen H3 and now I don't take the
Knight I don't take the bishop
I play a move to undevelop my only
developed piece
Bishop F1
and for those that can imagine that
position it's really beautiful
so Bishop will be trapping the queen
and it'll be
move 11.
I'll have all my pieces on the back rank
so I'm kind of hoping for that but we
don't quite have it
I'll share the the position after the
game
I think here I can happily take the
knights
now there's no Queen H4
and now it's time to
complete development
E5
is a playable move
but I'm really in no rush
if anything I just want a queen side
Castle
make sure my king is safe
I could play Knight C4
yeah Knight C4 looks nice
I was just creating ideas of taking the
bishop
do I take and give back the pawn Cube
uh I haven't seen a pawn cube in a while
or do I play Queen A4 first
and then take
yeah let's go for this
so I'm getting getting ready to take
and then flock takes and creates the
pawn Cube
I'll deliver checkmates
it'll be the worst Pawn cube of all time
except we're not getting that okay so I
think I'll still take the bishop
because if Pawn takes it's still mate
that pawn takes I can take on A7
and I'm
yeah I'm being a little bit greedy here
but I think it's with good intention
because now I can take here
and Lock's not quite trapping the queen
because I'll be able to take
and win another Pawn
although I have to be careful because if
I take the pawn with the bishop then
Rook AIDS
and then I'm actually
losing material I think because Queen B6
black wins a piece
but I'm already up a piece so I can
still be winning there
um maybe this is better Queen A5
yeah just ensuring that
my Queen's not getting stuck
and then if B6 I play Queen
back to A7
if that we're gonna have some fun
we're gonna have too much fun
oh no my Stafford gambits
Oh no you're Stafford Gambit
okay I think I killed the Stafford again
[Music]
what to do
I do want to share the funny line though
uh good game to my opponent yeah so if
F3 and engine's happy for uh for whites
but if Queen H4
G3 Queen H3 Bishop F1
it's just so weird to uh
be in a winning position after
11 moves with all the pieces on the
background
hey it's emberg I remember that funny
line ah Russell boss
Checkmate then later he almost beat you
in another game yeah I hope you had a
good birthday thank you Amberg
yes I guess um the other way to get that
same idea is if Queen H4
we can see I've had this before
Queen H4 is a move I would play as black
and then once my opponent played Queen
H3
and this was uh uh
the famous connect eight game somewhere
on YouTube
same idea where the Queen's trapped yeah
this was a
man this was
about two years ago
[Music]
if we look at the final position
spoiler alerts
we got here
B7 checkmate
I didn't lose upon that game
so anyway if this goes on YouTube
um I hope you learned something
I hope people are not too upset that the
Stafford Gambit is
kind of dead again
and I'll link the video of this game
below if you want to check it out
whoa It's Saiyan
with a hundred dollar hype chat
I think that's my my previous opponent
thanks so much really appreciate that I
hope you enjoyed the game I hope there
is some
some lessons to learn oh Sam says I
watch you all the time man thank you for
being being instructive
that's really kind